[Music]
the we're at Natural Balance pet foods
dog yoga aka Doga
I have two new rescues this is one of
them and I wanted to try this out and it
was the most relaxing thing I've ever
done in my life so this was just an hour
of just sitting there connecting with a
dog thinking about them and visualizing
what you want their life to be visual
ones chips lights gonna be well lots of
eating especially natural balanced food
he loves his hikes and now he's into
Doga do you ever sing to your dogs all
the time do you sing in sync songs to
them uh yeah although it makes me it was
my favorite one you know they really
liked that one it's a good one can you
give us like one of
the plants actually looks about the same
as he did back then and 2018 marks the
20th anniversary of instincts debut
albums worldwide release 20 years that
is insane and you know we we actually
are gonna be getting our star on the
Walk of Fame next year so that's the
perfect timing hey we'll do it for the
20th anniversary everybody can come out
with us you better believe it yeah I was
telling you guys we talked daily on a
group text and I'm like we need to show
up wearing the exact same like outfits
we wore in ninety-eight because we used
to dress the same which was so cheesy
but that was the 90s you know like it's
deal about the outfits back then he was
the most uncool Justin would have been
the one that was more into the fashion
back then and imagine that
there was some rumors that Justin
Brittany we're gonna be making music
together um I mean I I know he's been
working on music so I mean that would be
amazing I'd love that but I don't see it
happening why not I don't know I just I
I think I would have heard it you know
there's too much history there for that
to happen uh no I mean I think I mean I
would love to see it happen and I don't
think either of them would not want it
to happen I think they're good they're
friends and yeah it wouldn't be weird at
all okay get on group texting me okay
Bryce come on
[Music]
you